hello everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don Sakia and today we're
sitting down with Amy Farrah Weiss hey
great to be here thank you for coming on
the show thank appreciate it this is
exciting
Amy Farrah Weis is the founder and
director of the st. Francis homelessness
challenge and she's also running for San
Francisco mayor in 2018 and you also ran
in 2015
correct and then you scored 80,000 votes
that's that's a lot of votes first
second and third place because in San
Francisco we have rank choice voting so
that allows you to rank your first
second and third choice candidate so I
had 23,000 first place votes and a total
of nearly 80,000 first second and third
that's a lot of putting your voice and
ideas out in the public and getting them
to agree with you so that's a that's
that's that's a major indication of your
efforts so okay so let's let's start by
talking about your journey how how did
you hear you were telling me just a bit
ago you're born in San Jose went to De
Anza Community College and then so you
were like Silicon Valley baby had the
Macintosh whether you're growing up and
yeah so and then you kind of journey to
San Francisco and tell us about this
well it was quite a journey I was born
in Berkeley actually and then my parents
moved to San Jose when I was six months
old and on the salary of an appliance
salesman who worked at first Montgomery
Ward's and then Western appliance and
was a union member that was my dad and
my mom was a part-time registered nurse
and on that salary they could afford buy
a house when they were in their late 20s
in San Jose for $70,000 in 1977 Wow and
so completely different atmosphere today
where that same house they still live in
it and it's worth a million dollars
today and so the same opportunities just
don't exist but I'm the first generation
of my family to go to college and you
know for for me my advice from my
parents was get a scholarship that was
my guidance for college and
I ended up going to Dan's a Community
College which is really instrumental in
how I see the world today I learned
critical thinking skills there that I
didn't learn in high school I was part
of an Honors Program
while I was at DeAnza and so we had
small classes of about 15 people in a
class and there was an interdisciplinary
approach and so my first quarter there
we had a class on environmental studies
and there was also a class on Native
American philosophy and belief and they
were connected to one another and so
that idea of having a respect for the
indigenous people of California and the
United States as well as thinking about
our future with solar energy and it was
it was a great pairing and so then I
went to UC Santa Cruz and I majored in
sociology and while I was there this is
indicative of my style
I don't like to just learn things I want
to apply them and so while I was at UC
Santa Cruz in that two-year period I
ended up starting I created three
different independent study projects
where I did one internship at the Boys &
Girls Club working with at-risk youth
and designing a media literacy program I
worked at the Planned Parenthood of
Santa Cruz and did outreach and
education work and then I also worked
with the County Office of Education
focusing on living wages for child care
workers and that was all before I was 22
yeah while I was at college so that
gives you a little taste of what drives
me listen one more time for us so I
worked at Planned Parenthood at Boys and
Girls Club and the Santa Cruz County
Office of Education and then ended up
staying around Santa Cruz working for a
for-profit school that was focused on
online systems administration training
and it was an experience that taught me
about the dangers of working for a
private company at times because that
company ended up doing some wrongdoing
but when I was 23 I was sitting in a
room
of these executives of this company
called masters Institute in San Jose and
they asked me to do something that was
illegal and I was a supervisor and I
just said I'm not going to get the
trains to Auschwitz on time you know I
was I was trained at a young age too
it's just part of my nature that I won't
do things that compromise my integrity
or feel wrong to me and so at that early
age of 23 I was being told to do
something that was wrong and I took a
stand and I said I won't have the people
that are working for me do something
that's illegal and so then I moved to
Portland and I worked in transitional
housing there and I was also in bands so
as part of the DIY music and art scene
of Portland but also doing that social
work so I worked in transitional housing
for women I also went and worked on an
organic farm for a growing season in
Colorado because I wanted to understand
more about food production yeah I then
went back to Portland and worked with
at-risk youth focusing on harm reduction
pregnancy prevention and counseling work
and leadership development then I went
over to Massachusetts and worked at an
intentional healing community for people
coming out of psychiatric institutions I
worked at a psychiatric hospital in
Vermont came back to the West Coast and
weaved a Santa Cruz again worked at the
Santa Cruz AIDS Project in outreach and
education and harm reduction then I
moved to Oakland
then Berkeley and then in 2007 I moved
to San Francisco and I got reading work
with sustainability with businesses and
it sounds like you know a lot of the
work I'm doing what's the common thread
right because I'm doing all these
different types of fields for direct
service
I can't believe everything you just said
was Bill before 2007 Wow a lot and it's
all intertwined in that social fabric of
the world and that's really important
and it's a lot of it is for people of
low to medium income yeah
exactly and the focus that I see is that
I'm focused on individual collective and
organizational well-being and
empowerment and so when I was working in
this it's very good for me to have
worked in a variety of fields and worked
in you know the private sector the
nonprofit sector and the public sector
and understand the different challenges
that exist within all those three
sectors and then I was always drawn to
how is it that we can actually embody
our values more in this organization
what is it that we can do to streamline
processes maybe there needs to be a new
kind of orientation training for new
hires or maybe there's communication
issues in order to do the work on the
ground and what's coming up the line to
the department heads and so I've really
been focused on streamlining those
processes so in 2007 you know I decided
to go back to school and get my master's
degree and I wanted to do it in
organizational development and I was
thinking about going to use USF
University of San Francisco but that
would have put me $50,000 in debt and so
I decided instead to create my own
program at SF State so I started off in
the MPA the Masters of Public
Administration program there but then I
ended up creating my own program that I
called organizational development and I
worked with a local nonprofit that
focuses on mental health and housing
called progress foundation and I did an
assessment of their training program and
develop some new training modules for
them I did a needs assessment so that
was 2008 to 2010 and I had moved north
of the Panhandle at that point near
Divisadero and I think it's so important
for people who are moving to San
Francisco or you move into a new
neighborhood to do something similar to
what I did which was I did a research
project because people were saying that
living north of the pan
handle saying that you live north of the
Panhandle was a gentrifying term and
they were saying it's really called
Western Addition
and so I wanted to do this research to
see well what am i moving into because I
don't want to be someone who isn't
sensitive to the fact that I'm moving
into an established community that has a
history and so I did that research
project and in San Francisco you don't
have to go to par back to get to the
aloni right so we're talking about you
know the indigenous people that were
here and then the Spanish came and then
you go and do all this history but I
found out about when I did this research
project that the Western Addition was at
one point a thriving african-american
community with all of these businesses
and then unfortunately in the 1960s and
70s there was this redevelopment project
that started off as this righteous idea
at the federal level with harry truman's
1949 housing act but it got co-opted by
developers and the real estate industry
and so it turned into this terrible
redevelopment project that ended up
displacing all of these african-american
businesses and residents and at the end
of the redevelopment we had 3,000 less
units can you imagine a development
project today where the end result was
we lost 3,000 units rather than added
3,000 units so I learned about that
history and I was working with my
neighbors and I saw in 2011 that a Chase
Bank was getting a permit to be able to
they had already displaced two active
local businesses and they were taking
three small storefronts collapsing them
into one to create a Chase Bank and Ed
Lee's Department of Planning was bending
the law to the point of breaking it in a
couple of ways for Chase Bank and this
was after the global financial collapse
and so I hadn't been very knowledgeable
at that point about what had truly
caused the global financial collapse and
started to educate myself about the
economy and I and this is in 2011 I
learned about glass-steagall how
combining Investment Banking and savings
banking in 1999 led to this this risky
lending that tanked our economy and I
didn't understand how San Francisco on a
local level could be rewarding the
culprit for this devastation in my
neighborhood and so that in 2011 was
when I really finally saw the connection
between the national politics and the
local and the neighborhood and yeah up
until that point I had more focused on
you know every four years we vote for a
president and then I realized well this
actually gets implemented at the local
level so I started a nonprofit in 2011
called neighbors developing Divisadero
because I realized really there's a
Chase Bank just a couple more blocks
down the street and then those three
businesses they have it's a family they
have kids they have their livelihoods
they have their rent at their apartment
they also have their community that
there might be a you know one of them's
potentially a dry cleaner and other ones
potentially and in like Ethiopian food
or something right you know there's
there's all this intricacy that's not
even really considered it's just like
nope we need another location and how
can we bend the rules in order to get
that in so there's there's a whole slew
of conversations that need to happen
it's not as easy as money
here take it let's go let's let's get
rid of that let's move on to another
Chase Bank location yeah and that's why
you know when I when I lived over north
of the pandava on that I now live over
in like Mission know Valley area but
when I lived north to the Panhandle
there was something really charming and
special to me about saying that I lived
north of a park to be able to say I
lived north of a park and then to say I
live near the Divisadero quarter because
I grew up in San Jose and growing up in
San Jose you describe and in the
suburban part you describe where you
grew up in relation to the closest mall
so I lived I would
to people today if I say oh you grew up
in San Jose - I went to prospect high
school but I went to you know I lived
near Westgate Mall and El Paseo mall
whereas in San Francisco you get to say
you live north of a park near this
neighborhood commercial quarter which I
love but I realized that you could
actually protect that through the law
and so my neighbors who were protesting
this Chase Bank permit and asking for an
appeal took me under their wing and
helped me learn the zoning code and so
then I could see how it was that they
were manipulating the law in favor of
this Bank and like I said I realized at
that point it's not enough just to say
no because the progressive movement has
a righteous no to displacement to
gentrification - you know profit driven
motives that hurt the community and the
culture and I understand that no but I
started asking in 2011 well what's our
yes
what's our strategic yes to address
these solutions and I and I asked you
know I just wanted to learn because I
was new to local politics what is it
that we're asking for and I didn't hear
a clear vision of yes in 2011 so when I
started neighbors developing to visit
Darrow the focus was on our yes our
strategic yes to inclusive culturally
enriching and sustainable development we
have to become the developers so that we
protect against displacement but we also
have a vision for what we want to see
happening that's truly exciting and
inclusive and so that's what the focus
of neighbors developing Divisadero was
and then I decided to run for mayor in
2015 because there are so many things
that the Lee administration was doing or
not doing that I felt were harmful and
the wrong direction for the city after
the global financial collapse of the
late 2000s we had the opportunity this
our economy in a different direction and
there was like we're on Market Street
right now filming this Market Street had
for decades
tons of commercial properties and
storefront properties that were kept
vacant by the property owners because
guess what they actually get a tax
write-off oftentimes for keeping these
properties vacant and after this right
know in 2011 what we could have done was
we could have created a vacancy tax that
said you know basically not use it or
lose it but use it because we don't want
to harm the the culture in the community
and you keeping the storefront vacant
personal it purposefully is actually
doing damage to our economy and to our
public health and safety and so we're
going to make it so that there's a
disincentive to keep it vacant but what
did the city leaders do in 2011 the
exact opposite they gave the property
owners a huge game because they had the
Twitter tax break which allowed these
property owners to have basically an 80%
increase in their investment and their
return rather than making sure that they
activate these spaces in a way that's
communities serving so we went this
wrong directly to ask what do you mean
about the 80 percent increase so if you
look at what the rents were back in 2010
compared to what they are now I saw a
statistic that said that there was an
80% increase in rent so they were able
to get it you know who is benefited from
San Francisco policy in a year or just
from now to then so I saw one stat that
said there was an 80% increase and you
know I you know as as mayor as someone
who had a team of people working with me
salaries then go up 80% salaries didn't
go up 80% but the property owners
who owned this property and kept it
vacant were able to get a huge boost in
what they were able to charge for their
rent and so I know many businesses had
to leave Market Street because it was
now unaffordable the ones that had been
there through hard times right and
there's still hard times on Market
Street we still have a lot of work to do
to make it a thriving ecosystem all
around but why is it that these smaller
businesses and these local businesses
were kicked out in order to enrich the
property owners when they had done a
disservice to our economy and to our
neighborhoods and so that's a real key
piece is that if you this is not just
the the local this is the national who
has benefited since 2008 and this global
financial collapse the banks that were
too big to fail have gotten bigger and
more consolidated the property owners
and the developers have made out like
bandits but the people of San Francisco
we've seen this huge turnover where
hundreds of thousands literally hundreds
of thousands of people low to moderate
income have left San Francisco because
they just couldn't make it work or
they've been displaced victim of that
creates a true fair share economy so
that we can stay panned and whoever
becomes mayor and I hope it's me but
even if I don't become mayor I hope to
work with whoever is mayor to actually
create this fair share economy and over
the next year we really need to be
focusing on stabilizing our multiple
crises so stabilizing the encampment
crisis so that we make sure that people
have access to a toilet and secure place
to sleep there are 3,500 people living
on our streets that's a manageable
crisis but treat it like a crisis and
stabilize it we need to stabilize the
displacement make sure that people are
able to stay in their homes
we need to figure out how we're gonna
once we stabilize then we need to be
figuring out how are we gonna grow in
this exciting and sustainable way
because when people are talking about
growth in San Francisco right now I
think there's this fear about it because
how many more units are we gonna add and
who is that gonna benefit we have the
central soma plan that's being discussed
right now where they want to zone for
50,000 office jobs and 7,000 new units
of housing do you see a problem there
50,000 office jobs 7,000 units of
housing who are those jobs gonna go to
first if I commute into San Francisco
probably right and so if we're talking
about increasing the amount of tech
office jobs in Central Selma over the
next 10 years we need a mayor who's
going to focus on connecting the dots
between our current residents that are
in in school at San Francisco Unified
School District K through 12 CCSF and SF
State we want to make those really clear
pipelines to prosperity between our
current residents and these jobs we need
San Francisco residents to have the
skill set to build our city and to
maintain our city but also to develop
the technology of the future both that
that right there is the is such a key so
on one end we have this tech culture and
on the other and we have this the K
through 12 the kids that are being
raised in San Francisco where it's
unsafe and it's there's a lot of
homelessness and crimes it's just that's
not okay and then on the tech side of
things is there's not that much
involvement right now from the
technology sector and if we're gonna do
things like make a project
50,000 more tech jobs in Soma than we
need to have a discussion about how
those tech jobs can help benefit and
this crisis that's occurring and I think
you you really call it out as a crisis
and that's really important to do I
don't think I don't think we refer to it
as a crisis when we walk down the street
and we see what's going on we just refer
to it as happening right and so if
you've heard it as a crisis that almost
galvanizes people the community to be
like are what do we do let's talk about
it more often let's fix it let's make
things happen do you know have from from
speaking to two people and you're safe
organize spaces project do you know if
out of the 3,500 that are on the streets
do you know if many of them are
interested in staying on the street did
they do do some people actually prefer
to have that that freedom of just being
able to you know wake up wherever they
want and move their belongings from
place to place well most people if you
ask them would like a place to belong in
community so let's start there and
that's really the crux of this program
that I've been working on as the
director of the st. Francis homelessness
challenge is we need to heal this at the
root and at the root that means that
people need a place to belong because if
you go out and sleep on the street
because you don't have another place to
go you fell through the cracks with your
social network or your family and you
you have to figure out how you're not
going to get attacked tonight you have
to figure out where you're going to have
to go to the bathroom at 1:00 in the
morning if you need to go to the
bathroom where you're gonna go so that
causes trauma and so when what I'm
talking about doing is changing the
city's approach from currently we spend
thirty million dollars a year on SFPD
police officer response and Department
of Public Works cleaning response just
for encampments so that's a portion of
the the budget that just goes to
policing and
cleaning encampments 30 million dollars
a year that should shock everybody 30
million dollars a year to get the
results we're getting right now that's a
move along strategy what I'm saying is
we take that 30 million dollars and I
have already created a budget for this
I've piloted this we can scale it up so
that for 30 million dollars we could be
supporting 3,000 people in a you belong
strategy so it's going from move along
to you belong
but you belong with reasonable
agreements with the proper structure you
belong itís safe organized spaces are
the same or yeah I'm just saying that
we're the mentality behind safe
organized spaces is that you belong yeah
you are an individual you're a human
being we're going from treating you as a
problem to treating you as part of the
village right because these are the
focus is creating these transitional
villages you know in impacted
neighborhoods right now yes it's a
transitional village meaning it's a
stepping stone into a more sustainable
and permanent housing and work solution
after the transitional village sure and
to your question before do people want
to stay on the street there's a certain
amount of people that would prefer to
live in this safe organized space
transitional village for six months a
year maybe indefinitely because they've
actually become accustomed to living
off-grid but we can we still need to do
that in an organized way and that's the
thing is that I know many people have
been working with encampments directly
in San Francisco for a couple years now
and I know people that they actually
would be a great benefit to the city and
they are because they're they're
scavenging for things that have been
left on the street that are recyclable
or or they can yet they can take things
and
use them if we were to work with the
people who are currently unsheltered and
figure out what they have to offer and
give back then we can have a symbiotic
relationship but right now because we're
saying what you're doing is illegal you
can't live on the street but we're not
giving an alternative for an organised
version of it we get so much conflict
and of course this is also overlapping
with a mental health crisis as well as
an opioid addiction crisis so all these
things are interrelated but that's why
I'm talking about getting at the root of
it which is community community building
and then having reasonable agreements
and so what I like to say with the st.
Francis homelessness challenge is that
living in community is hard no matter
where you live whether you're in a condo
whether you're in an SRO single room
occupancy hotel whether you're in an
encampment living in community is
challenging what makes it work
reasonable agreements and structure and
responsibility and so what I'm trying to
do is shift our mentality to think about
how we address these issues as community
and like Karl Marx said you know if
we're talking about this socialist
framework each person needs to have
their needs met but what's the second
part of the line it's you know to each
according to their needs from each
according to their ability and so there
has to be this shift from people are
recipients as a problem to people are
participants and being part of the
solution yep and that's the framework
that I use the st. Francis homelessness
challenge and that's the same framework
I would use to actually address the
misery and the public health and safety
issues that are happening on Market
Street and Tenderloin in soma unless we
look to people as participants to shift
this together and put that funding in
the right place
rather than to deal with the symptoms
nothing's gonna change it's really we
need transformative policy right now
that is grounded in best practices and
research which which my approach
definitely is
you know I've studied policy I've built
programs I've evaluated programs and
even from an accounting perspective it
makes more money it makes more sense and
saves more money to heal at the root
rather than put money into cleaning our
streets and policing our streets and I'm
very concerned that I I was just at a
mayoral forum last night in the
Tenderloin
and I'm very concerned that my fellow
candidates are all talking about putting
more armed police officers on the street
as the solution no that is not the
solution the solution is to invest in
arts and culture programming eyes on the
street mental health programming
de-escalation programming and there are
already frameworks and existing
organizations that do some of this work
so we're not starting from scratch but
we need to fund that so that we create
eyes on the streets throughout these
high incident crime areas and then we
have a network where if people are
seeing there's a true issue we can call
the police right they are connected to
the police but the police aren't walking
around in in mass numbers just to
intimidate people into being community
oriented we actually have community
oriented programming that's working with
everybody and if need be we can network
to connect to the police but I don't
want to see an increase in the
Tenderloin of a hundred more police
officers that is not the solution it's
very costly it's not going to get us the
outcomes we want so we're talking a lot
about this route and it seems like you
have identified the route as community
and you've mentioned individualism and
collectivism both which are varying
to help people become part of the
solution a participant in the ecosystem
so you you drew up this I thought I
thought this was really interesting so
safe organized spaces a neighbour's
guide to community integrated
transitional villages so we see that up
here and then we see you know it's a
very friendly you know it's a very
friendly PDF here and you indicate that
there's three thousand on housed
residents sleeping outdoors there's a
wait list for shelters every night about
75 in camp mints and that's that thirty
million dollar figure that you were
talking about earlier
I actually just signed the petition so
organized spaces org yeah that was great
and this is your organizational
transitional Village so here's a general
idea of how over time we would slowly
aim to bring people that are currently
living in encampments into transitional
villages like this and there would be
the individual shelters some secured
storages and let me just speak to the
individual shelter piece so the city
right now is investing in navigation
centers is what they're calling them for
helping people transition off of the
street into housing and they're pretty
pricey it costs millions of dollars
generally to set up this navigation
Center which is basically just a low
barrier shelter and it can how is
usually up to a hundred and twenty five
people so millions of dollars to create
this these bungalows or a large tent
that can have you know 15 people in a
room up to a hundred and twenty five
people in a large tent think about your
pathway to recovery if you've been
living on the street for years what
would it be like to share a space and
open space at night with 15 other people
or a hundred other people it's really
challenging so the a key part to healing
is to have the space and the privacy to
breathe you know and to to feel secure
that
one's not gonna come up to you one of
your neighbors at night and do something
to you while you're sleeping there and
so these individual shelters are a key
part of healing we are they are we have
built so far with the st. Francis
homelessness challenge we built 13
shelters and we followed a code it's the
National Fire Protection Association
standards for small RVs we have these 5
by 8 by 8 shelters they're on wheels and
they meet this code and that's so
important because I've been trying to
work with the city for two and a half
years to be able to pilot this on a
larger scale and they keep pushing back
because they say oh these shelters that
you're making aren't up to standards
that is false they meet a standard and
we also have something that Phil Tang
our state assembly member from San
Francisco was able to pass at the state
level called Assembly Bill 932 which
allows us to create our own reasonable
standards to deal with the shelter
shortage crisis so if I'm mayor these
will be legal because they already are
it's just that the current City Hall
administration is pushing back against
having these individual shelters and why
individual shelters like we said they
create that privacy and space to breathe
there they're locking they create your
own storage that you can secure when
you're gone there's this communal
kitchen and meeting space as well which
is great so then there's the
individualism when you need to be locked
in your own healing as well as the
communal space right seems to be you
know toilets and hand-washing station
that's again that's just so important to
know where you can use the restroom when
you need to that's huge and that's why
we experience such dirty streets as well
now the one thing that you know that for
example like I'm interested to hear what
your thoughts are about the about like
Angeles Plan Angela Leo does plan with
what she's done with those mini clinics
on the bottom of of housing units that
she's helped push people in to get them
into sustainable permanent
supportive housing units there's where's
how would there be like kind of like the
support yeah would there be like the
clinic or the nursing good yeah yeah so
Angela is very focused on permanent
supportive housing exits from the street
and shelter which is wonderful and
that's what the city is already doing
really they're focusing on this housing
first model where they're putting their
energy and efforts into creating those
housing exits and that is important but
also it's equally important that we help
stabilize our neighbors in crisis who
are living without access to a toilet
and secure sleep right now because with
these plans with the city's current plan
or with Angela's plan my issue is that
it leaves thousands of people on the
street for years while we build those
housing exits and so my plan would be to
stabilize in a cost-effective community
integrated way now and then we do need
the work to create those permanent exits
that are supported like Angeles talking
about so I see these as complementary
Elementary and hers is a little longer
longer term in terms of timeline so
you're saying the transitional Village
these individual shelters can be created
faster correct and we built our shelters
we partnered with Asian neighborhood
design and Mission Housing Development
Corporation and so if I were mayor and a
position of authority at the Department
of homelessness we would actually get a
lot of support from businesses and
existing organizations to scale this up
and people who are currently homeless
there are many people who have
construction skills either basic or
advanced and so we built these shelters
with the support and help of currently
homeless people and we want to create
these pathways to prosperity right and
so what great project for to combine
with SF USD or CCSF for all these
different programs to build these
individual shelters and give people that
basic building and
action experience to build their own
shelter to support the building of other
it's not everybody's gonna be
experienced in building or want to build
and the idea is that everybody's a
participant and giving back in some way
to managing the village so there's 10
hours a week that you're you know
required to give back to helping staff
the village and make it function I've
has I've been tested already with the
transitional village they have villages
right now of this nature in Seattle they
also have an iteration of this model in
Oakland now where they have tough sheds
and they but the way that they're doing
it in these places is slightly different
from what I'm proposing which is that
participatory model so we're asking
people to participate and that's what I
learned when I worked at this place in
Massachusetts participate rather than
pay would be the yeah otherwise they
would pay if they didn't participate
that would be the well yeah and what you
could do as well as if people are
getting some kind of fixed income or
they start to earn income yeah I like
the idea of starting to take a third of
income and setting aside specifically
for their housing in the future so we
would get them used to that process of
having a third of their income going
towards rent but we wouldn't necessarily
take that to make the village operate we
would set it aside so that they'd be
saving money for their first and last
month's deposit or their rent along the
way you asked about service support yeah
so with this model the way that I've
structured it is that for every 20
people there's 60 hours of on-site
support and 3 different roles so there's
20 hours a week that's focused on
community integration so let's say this
village is in a parking lot somewhere or
it's on city property there's 20 hours a
week where someone is in this role of a
community integration manager so
their role is to make sure that the
license agreements are followed the
insurance you know policy is followed
that the villagers the property owner
and the neighbors and the service
workers were all simpatico great so
that's that one role then there's a role
of a resident empowerment organizer for
20 hours a week so the idea would be
that everyone would be required to go to
a weekly meeting who's part of the
village and that's it you know just one
meeting a week where you do a check-in
and this resident empowerment organizer
would help deal with conflicts that
arise let's say that Bob is having some
issues with Jim and we need to figure
out how to work that out that resident
empowerment organizer would work with
them because the goal is that you know
no one's doing harm to themselves or
others in this communal space and so if
someone gets triggered and threatens
like I want to punch you Bob
you know then we need to have a talk and
we need to work through it and maybe
that person maybe Jim needs to go to a
mediation session or a counseling
session once a day because that's what
he truly needs a daily check-in with
someone who has that support that can
help him figure out his plan for daily
meditation or mindfulness whatever it's
gonna take maybe he needs to start
taking his meds in a supported way
whatever it is that structure will build
around it so there's 20 hours as a you
know a general rule for each village of
someone supporting that empowerment
organizing but if if there was one place
that needed more then we could have more
structure built up around it maybe
there's 40 hours maybe maybe one space
needs 24/7 on-site support so it would
adjust to the needs of the particular
group because we ask them are there
other physicians or Nursing nurses on
there aren't nurses per se but there's
connection to those services right
there's a like that they would come
on-site if needed yes and so currently
with our pilot project we have now
partnered with a group called liberation
Institute that does free to low cost
mediation or they do counseling support
they do yoga and meditation they do all
these kind of things to support
well-being and they're they're trained
counselors licensed counselors so
there's a connection there that we could
build up with this we want to get people
the support that they need on-site as
much as possible because it's much
easier to say you know Jim be here at
2:00 p.m. on Friday rather than say Jim
go to this place 2:00 p.m. on Friday
although sometimes you need that
sometimes they need to go there seem
like the necessary health and wellness
people that would need to be should
potentially be one on the property
itself on in the transitional village
just because to be there right away to
help mediate or to help with a health
care issue just to be there right away
and that's not something that I in well
at least enjoyed understanding about
what Angela was saying about having the
mini clinic being on the bottom that
it's so close to be to to engage with
the people that are potentially going to
have a health care issue or a social
issue so I thought that was I'm really
interesting I also totally see how these
are not exclusive whatsoever to each
other that they're very much so part of
the same important like kind of like 1 2
3 equity for all movement of caring
about the people that are actually there
that are the that are sleeping in
encampments and in many cases bringing
on a little bit of insecurity letting
instability just I think of really easy
way to understand it like you said was
that
you need the security of knowing that as
you sleep at night that you can get a
comfortable full night's sleep without a
security issue happening or anything
that harms your so that's really crucial
and so I'm all for propelling a
transitional village as a test just like
Seattle did so you know we should
totally be testing this out and seeing
how this works
another thing that came to mind was that
a transitional village would need a lot
of not a lot but would need space and
it's in its we have the space you do and
yeah there's also a flat flat level
versus a building could stack up to
three four five floors
oh yeah the space in San Francisco where
you stabilize 3,500 people in community
I just went with a and I just want to
close the circle about the services
first there'd also be 20 hours a week
on-site transitional vocational support
and so it's all these three pieces where
you're helping people live in community
in the neighborhood that they're in and
then you're also helping people get on
that pathway to their end goals of
housing support so that's really crucial
but so about a month ago and you can see
this on my Facebook page you know just
to Amy Farrah Weis I I did a live stream
where I went with a current encampment
resident and we traveled all throughout
district 10 just it took us eight hours
to do it and I livestream the whole
thing us driving around and we took a
tally of how many tenths we saw
structures RVs so in district 10 which
is Bayview Dogpatch bait Hunters Point
Potrero Mission Bay Area we found four
hundred and thirteen tents and RVs
there's over 200 RVs and district ten
where people are living without plumbing
or any organization on the street and so
people are already living there first of
all
on the street so we've institutionalized
street living through our current system
let's let's keep that in mind but
overall there are probably about a
thousand people in district 10 if we
counted 413 you have to understand that
some people double and triple up in
these spaces and so let's say there's a
thousand people that are currently
living in district 10 we identified five
places that are city-owned property that
were just wide open space and district
10 that could accommodate all the people
that are currently there but what I
really like about this this idea of
activating underutilized space and
working with our unsheltered population
is that there are certain high crime
areas and so you could set up a five to
ten person village in an area that's
high crime and there's there's a little
parcel of land that could accommodate
five people or three people or twenty
people whatever it is and that would be
working together to have eyes on the
street and take care of that area so
instead of trying to fight the crime and
the areas in which people are getting up
to things because it's it's a removed
piece of property
we would actually be activating it in a
community way and requiring some kind of
community benefit piece so that keeping
people in these spaces it's almost like
a caretaker village in a sense because
we're asking people to take care of
their communities they're not gonna take
care of it unless they feel like they
belong in it right and so this will get
at some of our public safety issues as
well if we have these little villages
that are spread out and we have rules
and agreements and a social contract we
have to give people the opportunity to
get engaged in being part of the
solution
rather than feeling like we need to move
them out and and off of the street right
now we don't have the permanent
supportive housing I don't think the
answer is
put millions of dollars into these large
tent structures that we bring people
into I think it's creating community
where people already are and the
question for Angela the question for
mark and London and Jane what's gonna
happen 90 days into your term are we
gonna see any difference
autumns tracker those yeah are we gonna
see any difference with the Tenderloin
are we gonna see any difference with the
people living on the street I don't see
that plan in place right now that we're
gonna see any difference I see that
people are talking about putting more
money into the Department of Public
Works people are talking about putting
more money into police on the streets I
don't see any plan that's going to be
transformative in this way to actually
work with our unsheltered population and
the people who are in the Tenderloin and
soma to be participants in changing
what's happening and that's one of the
main reasons that I'm running for mayor
is that I don't see that plan and I I
want to be able to lead this process or
be part of co-leading it with whoever
becomes mayor if possible because I
actually have a transformative plan to
put into place I openly invite a mark or
London or Jane to come on to the
simulation show which is an open
invitation to you we haven't had you yet
we would love to have you so please we
will cut this clip out and send it to
your teams we invite you to come on mark
Leno London Bridge ain't imp Lee's come
on we'd love to have you for discussion
so I actually don't hear from them the
same sort of passion and enthusiasm that
I hear from you and Angela about the
crime the safety and the homelessness
where I really hear from you too and I
don't hear it from them so that's one of
the biggest indicators of that you guys
actually care about it and then another
thing that I just wanted to mention
about that is when that the plan of that
that you do to have you to have very
you two are deeply rooted you have skin
in the game regarding wanting to do this
you already have made impact at both of
you so one one of the one of the things
that you know that didn't come to mind
was the location of this currently you
said there is a space that you've
identified but now you have to try and
get this owners of the space on board -
oh well if the city had partnered with
me and they could do that today you know
this isn't something that it can't
happen even though it hasn't happened up
until this point the city could work
with me right now and say okay we're
gonna set aside some of this we're gonna
identify some of this Caltrans property
that you could activate to put a pilot
on this space they could start working
with me
well there's Caltrans land that's
available all throughout that just means
anywhere that's under a freeway or near
a freeway on-ramp or exit so for
instance those friends Caltrans yes the
property and the lease it to the city in
order to provide this support
transitional Village yes and so they're
doing that now on division as well as in
Soma where they're setting up these two
navigation centers on Caltrans land but
there's Mission Bay that has a lot of
parcels that are available there's
there's if if you are the mayor of San
Francisco and you have the will to treat
our unsheltered crisis as a crisis there
is plenty of space to be able to do this
like I said I drove around district 10
and we saw many empty parcels this could
also be partnerships with private
developers where we give them a property
tax rebate or support the eventual
development of a project on their land
if they allow us to lease it so it'd be
a lease there'd be insurance there'd be
a contracted nonprofit that would be
supporting the carrying out of this
ville
yeah so this is this is all there
waiting to be scaled up there is land
available to do this and the key is
though that we want to make sure that we
have a healthy ecosystem so right now we
have 3500 people that are living on the
street we have about 7000 people
altogether that are unsheltered that are
homeless that are either living on the
street or in shelters or in-between kind
of things we have an estimate about
20,000 people altogether that are
housing insecure right now and so it's
important for us to send this message to
the country to the Bay Area that whoever
becomes mayor if they're truly going to
take on this crisis we need to stabilize
who's here right now we are gonna focus
on who's here right now and we're gonna
focus on people who became homeless in
San Francisco and then we want to export
this in order to help other cities do
similar work to take on their crisis
yeah because it would be great to be
able to say oh yeah we want to take in
10,000 refugees from Puerto Rico or we
want to take in but there's all these
people a system like this in place to
help out with that transition well we
the thing is that it's a nice thought to
say we want to have the ability to take
in refugees in San Francisco but I want
to make it clear that right now we
should be focusing on stabilizing who's
here correct and then we can talk about
how it is that we can support people
coming in in the future to San Francisco
who need support but at this point we
couldn't take in 10,000 oh let's let's
let's keep chiming on like the rest of
that we have a lot still talked about
so okay so great so this makes total
sense I think this is a great first kind
of pillar and it seems like you already
have figured out a lot of it just time
to actually get it implemented and
and in place so other things that come
to mind are for example with we you were
mentioning earlier about the need for
you know for not not to hire additional
police officers or you tell correct me
if I'm wrong but just just the essence
of having police that actually live in
the cities are really important because
well Angela said that there is only 200
officers that I actually live here and
the other 1,600 after like commute in
and that's ridiculous because we're an
earthquake city and that shouldn't be
the case we need to have police living
in San Francisco
so we need to provide them as well as
teachers and and
ambulance workers firefighters with
housing in San Francisco that's
affordable for say I'd be able to live
in it there's that also decreasing a
police officers from a gun to a Taser or
enabling them have both just in case if
they would rather safely use a Taser
rather than a gun there's so many
lighted cigarettes I have a different
approach to Tasers I don't think we
should be introducing tasers at this
juncture yeah that's different on that
point because we should be focused on
truly training and equipping our
officers to be de-escalation experts and
we don't need another weapon right now
to be added to that mix even though you
could say a Taser is less lethal or
problematic than a gun tasers are still
weapons that can kill people and can
damage escalation first and then if
necessary then see that there's that if
necessary step but again it's all about
de-escalation about their police
officers mental health as laws the other
person's mental health which makes this
so much more complicated and difficult
why don't you explain the fair share
economy a little bit more so this was a
lot of the safe organized spaces that
would this is really good really
important this fair share economy
obviously that has to do with with
things like this but unpack that a
little bit more for us what is that
exactly
sure so I mean one way to look at this
is that if you look at this model of
democratic socialism in Scandinavian
countries like Sweden and Norway they
have a high GDP but they also have a
high GNH which is gross national
happiness rating and so there's this
opportunity for us to have prosperity as
individuals and as companies in the
United States and San Francisco but
we're making sure that in terms of the
profits that they're sustainable and
they're actually we're making sure that
everyone has their essential needs met
in community so that means everyone has
affordable housing
everyone has affordable healthcare which
is you know from physical to dental to
mental health everyone has access to
education childcare all of these things
are transit internet access is now one
of these things that everyone needs
access to so these basic needs and
essential needs need to be met in
society before we allow these
astronomical profits because there's
such a disparity between the haves and
the have-nots in our society and San
Francisco is currently an epicenter of
inequity but I want to flip the script
on that and one of the things that we
can do is that currently the tax rate at
the federal level went from thirty five
percent to twenty one percent for
corporations and so we have this
opportunity to really capture some of
that savings that are local and state
corporations have saved from this huge
tax cut and we can put that into
investing in affordable housing
development and supporting education in
San Francisco in California so there's a
great opportunity to do that and the
Coalition on homelessness has actually
put forward one of the first
proposals in order to capture some of
that money and and redistribute it to
create a good baseline healthy baseline
for our communities they want to put a
measure on the November 2018 ballot that
would put in additional tax on companies
that have over 50 million dollars in
gross receipts and then put that money
towards rent subsidies building
affordable housing or rehabilitating
affordable housing and getting people
into safe and secure spaces for shelter
so their proposal would bring in 300
million dollars a year in order to
support those essential needs and of
course having that money and spending
that money well are two different things
and I know that I as mayor have the
ability to look at that budget and
invest in the things that we need to and
use that money as wisely as possible
one of those things that I would like to
do is to create a pool of current
workers and families that are rent
burdened so they're paying more than 30
percent of their income towards rent I'm
currently a rent burdened resident by
the way but we would have a pool using
our online system through the mayor's
office of housing that if you're a
worker you're a teacher a nurse or
service worker and you're paying more
than 30 percent of your income towards
housing you could get into this pool and
we are going to be working to activate
empty units that are currently being
held empty as well as building more
affordable housing units and we want
those units to go to people who you know
are currently making more or paying more
than they can afford for their rent and
match them up to those new units and so
I have a lot of different ideas about
how we can actually start to finance
affordable housing and a way
that will pencil out for both developers
and for the affordable housing project I
have ideas about investing in the
development of additional dwelling units
which only costs $200,000 to build as
opposed to $700,000 to build for a new
high-rise affordable unit working with
property owners working with developers
and these public-private partnerships to
create that affordable housing so we
need to create the affordable housing
the fair share economy also refers to
like I said before making those
connections from our current residents
that are in our educational institutions
from k12 to CCSF to SF State really
investing and creating the programming
to connect the dots between our
residents who are in education
programming and these jobs that will be
there because like I said we want San
Francisco residents to be part of
building and maintaining San Francisco
healing and stabilizing San Francisco
and also developing the technology
that's going to you know help us balance
our climate developing the technology
that's going to allow us to create new
transit platforms that aren't
exploitative to workers you know so
these are the things that I'm focused on
is how do you get that balance in an
economy so that you can have individual
prosperity as well as companies that are
doing well but we're making sure that
we're meeting those essential needs of
our workforce and Families yeah so we
have the individual that needs to
prosper the collective that needs to
prosper the communities that need to be
built and you have a bunch of things
that you mentioned that kind of all are
on a pillar of so currently 30 you said
25 percent versus 31 percent in terms of
tax well the corporation's got a tax
reduction through the Republicans and
Trump from 35% of their of their profits
went to federal taxes and it got cut to
21% okay so that's 14% difference so
with a 14% difference that's at the you
know at the federal level okay so now
the question becomes at that point is
that's kind of where this all
precipitates from everything else that
you mentioned kind of comes right after
that so the question becomes if that 14%
is allocated to the federal government
and then the federal government can
redistribute that to the social fabric
organizations like st. francis
homelessness challenge all these other
important organizations about equity for
all will that be more effective than
leaving the 14% profit with the
corporations and then having them figure
out how to continue prospering the local
communities and economies in the areas
that they're already stationed in that's
kind of the overall overarching question
okay so we don't have to say that we're
gonna take that entire 14 percent of
saving course it can be a modest portion
of it but what's great about this is
that this is setting up California and
local cities within California to be in
a place where we can be sustainable for
our future economy outside of the
federal government and so it's so
important for us in California to be
investing in affordable housing
development and an education and
healthcare so these are the things that
California companies can now do more of
because they're not sending their money
to the federal government to support the
military and to support the red states
we have an opportunity to
pride in the fact that our corporations
can help build California so that they
can have a healthy ecosystem in which
they're a part of and they should be
excited to do that work with us and when
I'm talking about investing in
affordable housing you know we have a
big surplus at the state level right now
billions of dollars in surplus we should
be using that money to invest in zero to
low-interest financing a revolving loan
fund so that we can actually through the
state finance the affordable housing
aspect of new development and this is
what I'm really trying to get us all to
be thinking about in this mayor's race
and in general in California is we need
these new financing mechanisms in order
to support affordable housing
development partnering with market rate
developers and I just talked to David
Campos today who is now working in the
Santa Clara County government and he's
also the head of the Democratic Party in
San Francisco and he was telling me that
this idea of I was asking him what he
thought about this zero to low-interest
financing revolving loan fund and he
said well that's what we're doing in
Santa Clara now because Santa Clara
County put a billion dollar housing bond
on the ballot and it passed and so
they're doing funding projects and
what's great about that is that up until
now we've relied on federal tax credits
in order to build our affordable housing
and that's really just a giveaway but if
we do the financing for the affordable
housing then it comes back to us with
rents right it's not that we're just
giving money away it's that over time
that gets repaid but in a way that makes
sense for the developer to be able to
pay off the project so this is a
direction that's now I got it confirmed
that this is a good idea because it's
happening in Santa Clara County
and you know it would really help us do
that is to have a state bank or a
municipal bank where we could have that
revolving loan fund and so we have a
governor's race coming up d'Alene Easton
I know supports a state bank
so does Gayle McLaughlin he's running
for lieutenant governor Delaney Stearns
running for governor I don't know if any
of the other candidates actually support
a state bank but what does that mean
what would that look like
a state bank is chartered territory
because North Dakota has a state bank
and North Dakota warned us back in 1999
when glass-steagall was repealed and
investment banking and savings banking
came back together again under the same
umbrella North Dakota's senator said
look out within ten years we're gonna
have a bust because the bank's can't
help themselves they're gonna do too
many risky practices to get huge profit
and they were right but North Dakota
wasn't impacted in the same way because
they have a state bank so they they
weren't impacted by the global financial
collapse brought on by this these risky
procedures of the big banks and so
they're the state bank prevent them from
oh because they they are in charge of
their own investments and and practices
whereas if you had most most governments
are investing their money in large banks
right so Wiis bank the west and San
Francisco to port we have a ten billion
dollar budget and five billion dollars
of that is discretionary so we store
that money somewhere right it's in a big
bank and so if they go under we go under
whereas with the state bank they weren't
making risky practical lending practices
although let's be real in North Dakota
one of the issues with their state bank
is there a lot of the investment is
coming from fracking so that's
unfortunate and we don't want to
replicate that piece of it but San
Francisco actually has a very similar
budget to the whole state of North
you know we have a $10,000,000 budget
they have a similar amount of money that
they're managing with this but why I say
we should be focusing on getting our
elected officials to support a state
bank is there's already a procedure for
it we know how to do it
whereas municipal banks we've been
trying to push that for it in San
Francisco for a while and a lot of other
cities are but it's not it's literally
unchartered territory there isn't a
municipal bank charter for our system
right now for banking and so San
Francisco could become a member of a
state bank and that would be a lot
easier than us creating our own
municipal bank but then we wouldn't have
to pay the fees the interest would go
into development projects for affordable
housing education you know so we have
the opportunity to control that amount
of money and financing if we have the
the structure for it so State Bank is
something that I'm very supportive of as
well as exploring the the new procedures
for creating a Municipal Bank in San
Francisco and then the outcomes tracker
is also really interesting tell us a
little bit about the outcomes tracker
yeah so you know a lot of candidates
make promises about what they're going
to accomplish over this next year
because remember that this next mayor's
term is only a year and a half it would
start in June 2018 and then it would go
until essentially January 2020 because
there's another election in November
2019 so next year in November there's
gonna be another election and we want to
have a way to track progress of whoever
becomes mayor so I've created something
called an outcomes tracker and you can
get to it a twice for mayor comm where
I've listed all the things that as a
mayor I would be able to accomplish over
the next year
and it could be measured any candidate
who becomes the mayor should be held
accountable to their promises and to
similar outcomes tracking about public
safety about how many people have been
stabilized if we're seeing any
difference on the street with
encampments so all of these types of
things but I've I've put together what I
think is a manageable list of what I
could accomplish as mayor and it you can
find it at wifes for mayor comm I'm
trying to work with the Democratic Party
of San Francisco unions media to join me
in creating a process that voters and
all of these stakeholders we could keep
tabs on what's truly accomplished over
the next year and whoever becomes mayor
they're gonna have their work cut out
for them right but they're also gonna
have the spotlight on them because
there's another election coming up in
2019 so the candidates who don't become
mayor are most likely gonna keep running
and they're going to try to say that the
person who became mayor isn't cutting
the mustard and they need to to be
elected in November 2019 so it's going
to be a really challenging position for
whoever becomes selected mayor because
they're really going and this is what
they should do is just put their head to
the ground right and focus on getting
things done not focus on campaigning to
be the next mayor but just have their
work speak for itself over this next
year focus on stabilizing focus on
creating this vision exciting vision for
how we're gonna grow sustainably but
really focus on stabilizing over this
next year and show us what they can
accomplish show me don't tell me and
that's the outcomes tracker
is that we need to see what's
accomplished over this next year and I
also love the idea of whoever becomes
mayor if it's me I will work with all
the other candidates on their passion
projects and their areas of expertise
and I hope that whoever becomes mayor
does the same thing
yeah where you know mark Leno is talking
about how he wants to activate 1500 SRO
units that are currently empty great
Jane Kim is talking about expanding
early childhood education great
Angela Alioto is talking about permanent
supportive housing great London breed is
talking about now as something I've been
talking about as well which is a program
to support additional dwelling unit
construction and financing great so
we've all we've all got our how do we do
it all at the same time well we could
who the next mayor of San Francisco and
if it's me I can guarantee this but if
it's another person I hope they do this
should be working with all these
candidates because we're in an era where
even with the superhero movies now it's
not just one superhero now it's the team
mm-hmm right so in a way you have five
superheroes that are running for mayor
of San Francisco right now wouldn't it
be more exciting if together we lent our
skills and and truly focused on serving
the people of San Francisco serving our
ecosystem serving a fair share economy
and and really show that we're in this
for the right reasons which is to heal
and stabilize and grow sustainably
rather than pit against each other in
order to win all the movies are moving
towards the superhero team yeah I love
the notion that you know you you all
have your different skill sets that you
want to bring to the table and the
different ideas that you've built in
that oh you're are building okay let's
walk you through a couple of our
simulation questions so I think though
probably one of the most relatable
questions is about wealth and equality
as the wealth gets concentrated eight
people have about as much wealth as the
bottom four billion people what do we do
about that wealth and equality
especially as all these exponential
technologies like biotech and AI and
robotics are taking off what do we do
well one thing we do is we support this
proposed measure that's going to be on
the ballot in November to
tax companies with very high revenue and
give that back to supporting people who
are in the lowest tier so that's
something that we can do is you think
that that practice is a sustainable
proven practice of taxing a company more
money taking that money and trying to
make that money be as impactful as
possible versus allowing that company to
take that additional profit and rather
than adding a zero to the end of the
person's check at the end of the year
they would take that money and try and
figure out themselves as a company how
to properly give back themselves oh it's
it's demonstrated that we need to have
the funds to invest in affordable
housing development and stabilization
and just having a community benefits
package like they do with the Twitter
tax break you know where they have
volunteer days and they can decide where
they're gonna give some of that extra
money back that's not working it's not
working now so we and and if you look at
the tax rates in I mean history of well
buys are not work when a company says
that they're they can decide where they
want to you know put money into the
temple project in the Tenderloin or they
want to put volunteer hours is it
working look outside well we we create
we did approach in 2011 for the Twitter
tax break and who is it benefited it's
benefitted corporations and property
owners and banks that's who's benefited
after 2011 with that model so if you
look at the taxation rates in the United
States over time it's been less and less
that people are responsible for giving a
portion back that's going to sustain the
workforce and our families and and
residents with having their essential
needs met and so I truly believe that we
need to do some fair redistribution of
that wealth inequality to support people
with their basic needs
that's gonna benefit Ron Conway Ron
Conway will benefit from me being mayor
because right now there's such wealth
inequality and so many issues that it's
hard for a very wealthy person to truly
enjoy San Francisco because they see
this disparity if you invest in the kind
of programming and heal at the root and
the way that I want to as mayor we can
have great business business and
government relationships but we're but
we have to use that money wisely and
account for it and and that's what I
want to bring to government is that same
kind of business approach where you're
you have performance metrics you're
you're very focused on accountability in
terms of how you spend your money and
what kind of outcomes you're getting and
I know how to stretch a budget like
nobody's business you know because I've
been very low income for most of my
adult life just to you know do the work
that I want to do and so people probably
can't believe that I currently make less
than $15,000 a year and I have for most
of my time in San Francisco and I still
function and and do a lot with that
that's because I have priorities yeah
and so as mayor I would demonstrate this
by taking two hundred thousand dollars
of the mayor's salary and putting it
back into a pool to redistribute so that
programs have the resources that they
need as well as we can lift up some of
those those nonprofit subcontracted
salaries where people are making you
know $15 an hour bump it up to $17 an
hour you know which gives them a little
bit extra to work with I want to show
from the top I call it a Titan from the
top to bolster the base strategy where
and I'm not just walking I'm not just
talking the talk I'm walking the talk
because I would take $200,000 of my own
and put it back in to redistribute and
it seems rare but I am one of those
people that will personally
inconvenience myself or take less in
order to support the greater good
and I think we need that kind of
revolution of love and logic in our
society as a city as a state as a
country where it's a fair share we're
giving our fair share we're taking our
fair share and it's it's a whole
transformative way of thinking because
that's those aren't the American values
that I was taught growing up that but I
want to we have the ability to shape
American values and what better place
than San Francisco to actually be that
epicenter of a fair share economy and
the other thing we can do for economic
equity is that we can really focus on
creating worker coops and creating new
models of public benefit corporations so
that we're making sure that companies
have greater pay parity and that workers
are treated with dignity whether or not
they're cleaning a bedpan or they're
running the city it's work and that
should be treated with dignity and you
should have your essential needs met if
you're doing your work
are you inspired I am i I'm so just I've
had so many influences over my life that
have put me into a very free-thinking
position over time
lots of conservativism lots of
liberalism lots of free thinking and so
because of that I am very unsure about
what is the best way to actually move
forward and that's why I you know I
always question conservatives wanting
just to take home all of the money and
and be like oh yeah we don't just buy a
third yacht we also fund lots of
important projects but then I'm also
very skeptical of of taking and taxing
the profits on companies so greatly that
it in in it in hey
it hinders them from not only wanting to
make some social change that occurs of
the some altruistic change but also from
them developing and expanding their
products that can potentially enrich
other places in the Midwest of the US or
even in India or other places in the
world so so it's just it's hyper
multivariate it's probably the most
multivariate thing is do you tax more or
do you not tax more and why so that's
crazy difficult to unpack and that
pretty much has everything to do with a
lot of what San Francisco can do with
potentially that money or without that
money could they could we convince them
to somehow want to give back or would
they be convinced to give back so that's
a whole huge thing to unpack but what's
beautiful about it is that we're
actually not saying they have to pay
more taxes because they just got this
huge tax cut at the federal level and so
we're saying a portion of that will go
into building the place where your
company is and sustaining it right so
putting more corporate social
responsibility on supporting the whole
ecosystem of the place where your
company is based so but it's still they
got a tax cut and now we're still asking
for them to take a portion of what they
saved and invest that back into the city
correct that's what we're asking I think
that's a very fair ask now the question
is mandating that versus asking for it
there's a big difference and then
there's also the meditation or spiritual
side of things which is once one manages
themselves and becomes very enlightened
then they don't even need somebody to
come up and ask them to do it they just
choose to do it because it's part of
their understanding of the collective
consciousness the individualism but also
the collective or culture the
environment all that stuff so so that is
I guess where we're moving we'll see
what ends up happening with that so I'm
really happy that you're working on the
st. francis homelessness challenge this
that is that is a very important thing
to just continue pressing into people's
minds
and over again is like how can we
humanely walk down Market Street and see
50% of people on the street in rough
circumstances whether or not they want
to be or not and then the other 50% of
people are techies that make over 100k a
year that have lived here six months or
a year or whatever how can that be
something that's just normally okay it's
just the fact that's okay and there was
another thing that I recently retweeted
about that I thought was ridiculous but
there's like all these new electric
scooters that are parked all over the
city and it's just ridiculous seeing
like 20 unused VC funded electric
scooters next to a dying homeless person
so that stuff's just ridiculous and it's
just you know it's creeping into my
blood and my you know my genes and I'm
just so over just seeing it and feeling
it and being within it I'm just so over
that and I just don't want to figure out
the best strategies and I want to work
together with the poor the middle class
and the rich to figure out how to do it
and there's just there's not one
specific golden key right now but we
should try and figure out what that
golden key is and bring it into
existence definitely yeah
and I think people like you are totally
on your you're you're so immerse you of
a lot of skin in the game which is
really important you've hired your
experience has a lot of skin in the game
and because of that you've you've really
gotten to understand a lot of the
different variables that go into the
equation a lot that you know probably
one of the most understanding of the you
know the more of like the liberal take
on this on this perspective and I
definitely challenge a lot of people
that are on the very conservative take
on this position to at least be
open-minded to what you know Amy Farrah
Weis is up to and what her perspectives
are and you know the opposite is also
true with very liberal the with the way
if they need to also be very open-minded
of how and why you're thinking in the
conservative way you might be so that's
a lot of what our show is about and I'm
glad that we had the opportunity to do
this
maybe we walk down just a couple more
questions what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world the most
beautiful thing in the world
goodness I think you know just on a
personal spiritual level it's
understanding that you belong as a human
being if you can get to that space you
know as an individual where you don't
question the fact that you belong in
community and in life that's something
that is hard one for most of us and then
also creating that space of
understanding that there's a difference
between your thoughts and your impulses
and desires and your actions so if you
truly understand that as a human being
that you can do bad but you can't be bad
and there's a distinction between our
thoughts and impulses and desires and
what we actually act upon those things
to me are truly beautiful I support you
know truth and justice and well-being
for all and so just the fact that people
put effort into supporting well-being
and reducing harm and creating that
sense of belonging anywhere that's
happening that's truly beautiful - yeah
I totally feel you that if someone feels
like they're a piece within the puzzle
versus not that's really important
feeling to have and I think everybody
can agree that that is something that is
so crucial all right and then how about
do you think we're alone in the cosmos
oh well you know I think it's really
important to approach our knowledge in
this way of its we should be humble and
say what we don't know and what we would
like to know and so that to me means
that we are open to learn
and we accept the limitations of our
current knowledge without pretending
that we know more than we do
so I was raised as a fundamentalist
Christian and so there's there's a
shutting down of awareness and
consciousness and humbleness about a
humility about what we don't know in
that religion and so I like to just be
able to say you know there's so much we
don't know but we want to learn more and
the way it currently looks like I would
say that you know there was a big bang
here we have evolved you know billions
of years later this consciousness and
consciousness is what the universe
actually grows over time but I would
imagine that there are many there's a
multiverse approach I think would be
more accurate of a hypothesis at this
point so that this this happens again
and again where there's the initiation
of matter energy that evolves to a
certain level of consciousness expanding
and having it being self-aware and that
this is happening in you know in many
iterations and life just is you know
like it just is we we didn't get to
choose this process we didn't you know
to my knowledge we didn't get to choose
any of this it's just life is and then
we are human beings and we do our best
to understand what's happening and use
our consciousness to reduce harm and
increase well-being which means just
being able to enjoy the experience as
much as possible but it's a pretty
brutal universe where life requires that
we consume other life in order to live I
wouldn't design
first this way it's very brutal there's
so much suffering but at the same time
it is and we can do our best as humanity
to understand to seek more knowledge and
to improve upon the systems that we have
to support life yeah that was beautiful
what a great way to end the show that
was so well said that's really
appreciated that and I know Ron did too
right you're on yes thank you
I love Amy yeah Amy you are so wonderful
thank you for everything you're doing in
our world we really appreciate it
WAIS for mayor comm is the links in the
bio go check out all the beautiful work
that their they have done that they are
doing with the campaign alright so you
guys know the you guys know the
procedure now if you had a good time
like comment subscribe definitely share
the content with other people get them
excited about it if you could help us
out we have a roof over our heads
electricity internet supporting our
guests all that stuff we have to pay for
all that
join us on patreon that'd be a huge
support thank you so much thank you Amy
yeah thank you thank you alright talk to
you guys some more later today
[Music]
[Music]